في اطار الهجوم المضاد الذي تشنه منذ اشهر
اعلنت اوكرانيا انها استعادت من القوات
الروسيه حوالي سبعه كيلومترات مربعه من
الاراضي في جنوب وشرق البلاد
اليوم اريد ان اخص بالذكر جميع الجنود
الذين يقاتلون من اجل استرجاع الاراضي
والتحريرها في باخموت واخص بذكر اولئك
الذين استعادوا
الاخرى واعني قوات الدفاع الجوي والمدفعيه
والشرطه الوطنيه شكرا لكم
لاحوا الجو الاوكراني اعلنا انه
اثقرت مسيره وس صاروخا اطلقتها روسيا خلال
هجمات ليليه جديده في اطار الغزو الذي
بداته موسكو عام 2022 كما اعلن سلاح الجو
الاوكراني اعتراضه 17 صاروخ كروز اما في
منطقه اوديسا اسقطت احدى عشره مسيره كانت
تستهدف منشات ساحليه في مدينه فيلكوفيل
المطله على النهر الدانوب دون تسجيل ضحايا
بينما ادى حطام مسيره دمرت في منطقه ميكو
لايف الى حريق في مبنى فارغ في بلده
دون سقوط ضحايا وكانت روسيا قد اعلنت ليلى
الاحد الاثنين بانها اسقطت عده طائرات
مسيره اوكرانيه فوق شبه جزيره القرم وفي
اجواء منطقه موسكو وايضا فوق بيل قرود
وفورونيج القريبتين من الحدود مع اوكرانيا